[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the mathematics of general
relativity part 7
the einstein equation
our mathematical model is finished
on the one hand we know how to describe
a space-time geometry
its curvature and to deduce how objects
naturally move
thanks to the geodesic equation for this
we have developed a whole set of
mathematical tools such as the metric
tensor
the christopher symbols the riemann
curvature tensor
the richie tensor and the richie scalar
on the other hand we also know how to
describe the energy content of the
universe
and thus the bodies that it contains
along with their motion
using a single tool the energy momentum
tensor
the most powerful idea in general
relativity will be to equate
these two notions using a single
relation
we will write an equality between
curvature and content
this equation which reads as an equality
between the geometry and the content of
the universe
is called the einstein equation
in our mathematical model the einstein
equation is the only one that cannot be
proven
it is inferred from observations
postulated because it describes very
well the world around us
this equation contains all the
predictive quality of general relativity
it allows us to directly relate the
abstract mathematical model
to concrete predictions about the
universe
usually the einstein equation takes the
following form all terms to the left of
the equation
represent the geometry of space time
they involve the richy tensor
the richie scalar and the metric tensor
the term to the right of the equation
corresponds to the contents
it is simply the energy momentum tensor
multiplied by a certain constant
which determines the intensity of
gravity in the universe
this constant depends on the speed of
light and on newton's gravitational
constant
it is chosen so that relativity is
compatible with older theories
and recovers newtonian gravity when the
pull is weak
it is important to understand that the
einstein equation
is extremely hard to solve as we saw
previously
the richie tenser and the richie scalar
which appear on the left of the equation
contain complex calculations involving
derivatives
sums and products of the metric tensor
moreover the two sides of the equation
are closely related
the content of the universe tells
space-time how to bend
but conversely the curvature of
space-time dictates
how objects move
solving such an intricate problem on
paper is almost impossible
in most cases it is necessary to make
approximations
and computer simulations to solve such
[Music]
problems
in the einstein equation the curvature
of space-time is embodied by the rich
tensor and the richie scalar which is
its contraction
but in a four-dimensional space time
like ours
the equation has a very interesting
symmetry
it remains valid if we swap the energy
momentum tensor
with the richie tensor and invert the
gravitational constant
this new equation is completely
equivalent and we will see that in some
cases
it can be easier to use
[Music]
einstein's equation is very complex but
it still accepts a number of exact
solutions
the simplest and most practical is the
following
let us imagine an empty universe in
which we place a massive body
of mass capital m we suppose that it is
spherical
static that is to say that it does not
evolve over time
and that it has no electric or magnetic
properties
this body may represent a star like the
sun
or a planet like the earth our goal is
to determine the metric tensor and
therefore the geometry of space time
at a point outside the object
first let's choose a coordinate system
we decide to observe the point from a
very far distance
and we measure time on our clock t
the distance between the point and the
center of the body
r and two angles theta and phi
our point sits in a vacuum therefore the
energy momentum tensor
is zero using the second version of
einstein's equation
we deduce that the rich utensil at this
point must
also be zero
to determine the metric from the rich
tensor the calculations are tedious
and require solving multiple
differential equations
but thanks to the symmetries that we
postulated for the problem
it is still possible to obtain an exact
expression
this is the schwarzschild metric
[Music]
the schwarzschild metric depends on the
mass of the object
if the mass is equal to zero we recover
the minkowski metric
describing an empty space-time
but around the body like the earth the
schwarzschild metric indicates that
space-time is curved
and the closer we get to the planet the
greater the curvature becomes
in the case of a planet its surface
prevents us from going
too close to the center and inside the
planet the schwarzschild metric
is no longer valid but in the case of a
sufficiently compact object
whose surface is very close to its
center we would be able to get close
enough
in order to reach a distance at which
the temporal term of the metric
with these coordinates is zero
we have reached a point of no return
time is infinitely stretched
compared to the outside this is the
schwarzschild radius
the horizon of a black hole
you